How many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week do you waste?
The classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day.
You know,
inefficient studying,
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done.
That's probably four hours right there.
No,
what you think,
well,
that's 2025 hours a week.
It's $100 a month.
That's two and a half full work weeks.
It's half a year of work weeks per year.
And if your time is worth $20 an hour,
which is a radical undressed,
but it's probably more like 50 if you
think about it in terms of deferred
wages,
if you're wasting 20 hours a week,
you're wasting $50,000
a year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young.
Wasting $50,000
a year is a way bigger catastrophe than
it would be for me to waste it because
I'm not going to last nearly as long.
And so if your life isn't everything,
it could be,
you could ask yourself,
well,
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you?
You'd be who knows how much more
efficient,
10 times more efficient,
20 times more efficient.
That's the prieto distribution.
You have no idea how efficient,
efficient people get.
It's completely,
it's off the charts while and if we all
got her act together collectively and
stopped making things worse,
because that's another thing people do
all the time.
Not only do they not do what they should
to make things better,
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or or
homicidal or genocidal or all of those
things all bundled together in an
absolutely pathological package.
If people stopped really,
really trying just to make things worse,
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that.
So there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability,
social judgment,
both of which are are,
are,
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt.
And that's the thing that's interesting
too is that I know like one of the,
another thing I've asked often ask my
undergraduate classes is,
you know,
there's this idea that,
that people have that people have a
conscience.
You know what the conscience is.
It's,
it's this feeling or voice you have in
your head just before you do something
that you know is stupid telling you that
probably you shouldn't do that stupid
thing.
You don't have to listen to it strangely
enough.
But you go ahead and do it anyways and
then,
Oh of course,
exactly what the conscience told you was
going to happen inevitably happen so
that you'll feel even stupider about it
then you would if it happened by
accident.
Cause you know,
I knew this was going to happen.
I got a warning it was going to happen
and I went and did it anyways.
And the funny thing too is that that
conscience operates within people and we
really don't understand the hell that
is.
So you might say,
well,
what would happen if you abided by your
conscience for five years or for 10
years?
What sort of position might you be in?
What sort of family might you have?
What sort of relationship might you be
able to forge?
And you can be bloody sure that a
relationship that's forged on the basis
of who you actually are is going to be a
lot stronger and more welcome than one
that's forged on the basis of who you
aren't.
Now of course that means that the person
you're with has to deal with the full
force of you in all your ability and
your catastrophe and that's a very,
very difficult thing to negotiate.
But if you do negotiate it well at least
you have something,
you have somewhere solid to stand and
you have somewhere to live.
You have a real life and it's a great
basis upon which to bring children into
the world,
for example,
because you can have an actual
relationship with them instead of
torturing them half to death,
which is what happens in a tremendous,
a tremendously large minority of cases.
Well,
it's more than that too because,
and this is what I'll close with,
and this is why I wanted to introduce
social knutson's writings to you.
You see,
because it isn't merely that your fate
depends on whether or not you get your
act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being.
It isn't only your fate,
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with.
And so you know,
you think,
well,
there's 9 billion,
7 billion people in the world are going
to peak at about 9 billion by the way,
and then it'll decline rapidly,
but 7 billion people in the world,
and who are you?
You're just one little dust mote among
that 7 billion.
And so it really doesn't matter what you
do or don't do,
but that's simply not the case.
It's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network,
you're a node in a network.
Of course,
that's even more true now that we have
social media.
You'll,
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life,
and they'll know a thousand people each,
and that puts you one person away from
1,000,002
persons away from a billion.
And so that's how you're connected and
the things you do,
they're like dropping a stone in a pond.
The ripples move outward and the affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend,
and it means that the things that you do
and that you don't do are far more
important than you think.